oops no thick welcome to this video
playing casablanca from from denmark be
3dr playing this wacky bishop d6 line
but it's not bad one of them most
popular ways to play against them
against be three Knight f3 here I go
here I want to see doing maybe not yeah
94 probably yeah I know this looks a bit
strange this Knight a5 business but this
is really the way it is played wow you
can give me the what ok what is the idea
girl oh wait besides ok this is probably
the quickest win yeah what am I doing
with this I cannot upload that what the
heck well ok treat this as a bonus game
and I'm the real game is the next one
requesting a new game and this is just a
77 movement of a piece with no one yeah
nothing nothing more let's see I get
some get Jane started yeah yes the
here's the real game let's end let's
hope it's not a 7 boy again against
tiger Bedrosian from Finland and played
him just recently and it was a win but I
don't remember what what game it was ok
Kings in you I could ok I kept I could
play that the real classical for once
don't usually play the line simply
because some
in the absolute main line with 96 I'm
not sure what line I i should i should
play i don't i don't like them the race
type positions very much like in the
corner variation well blanket x and y
just trying to to diminish blacks
kingside initiative it's not the kind of
position that i like too much ok so here
we we have a typical position well like
has played c5 putting up a solid wall in
the center oh this is interesting didn't
expect that yeah I didn't expect that
because I managed to play a four a five
now he's not in a position to block it
with a five or prevent my own a 45 okay
interesting yeah I could even just take
it Bishop g3 it's not clear what it is
doing yeah come on let's just let's just
take it and then a five this should be
should be a comfortable position I'm
threatening to really win the porn so
yeah it's hard to do anything else
probably needed to do that but this is
just very nice right I get them oh wait
wait for a moment here
Quincy six mmm the special d 7 um ok
hmm
yeah I wonder he's maybe just taking
here yeah that's not the end of the
world okay let's let's grab this first
and then see what happens yeah now I
have night a 4 but you will certainly
place stuff like Knight f3 check then
and get counted late neither threesome
of that I need to need to reckon with so
very much possible
hmm
yeah very interesting the rook on the B
file is not doing much okay I'm try to
try to use the deep pond
I actually planned after Knight f3 to
take with the bishop takes and then d 6
but Queen g5 and Queen h5 is very
dangerous yeah this move I didn't expect
it off it's very passive really very
passive it's not be 5 or 94 yeah yeah I
can implant idea for ya because if he
gives the check is just just not not so
dangerous anymore Queen d6 is a strange
decision
check yeah but now it's it's far less
threatening if I take it pawn takes yeah
that's still dangerous okay if I take
with the Queen what is this response
Queen Queen a six maybe yeah but when a
six the queen is far away from the
action okay take it down on o Queen g4 I
didn't I didn't think about that one Wow
I know not not a queen g7 with Quincy
for coming what a joke I didn't see that
move at all that's stupid
yeah very stupid plane I just forgot
about this one that the crew the queen
is so quick to talk I'm morning yeah I
can resign the light resides that was
giving away a completely great position
Queen d6 is just just outlandishly bad
but i just didn't i didn't reviewed it
27 affairs i did i just forgot that this
is possible okay what what moves are
winning here probably more than one move
what is what is a computer giving to
keep it simple Queen eighth Queen a
three yeah that's that's a very good
move actually Queen a three with this
this idea and it intends to get the
Queen back for defense it's very nice
the compass on plus one point for
basically winning yeah but they're
probably more wins just not what I
played probably yeah it was clear that
this happened but this would happen but
I just forgot about 27 I mean overlooked
it whatever you you want to call it here
it's already tricky I really relied on
the smooth after g3 there's also this
this IDM winning I forgot about Queen d7
really that this is possible and what
about other moves are the most winning
as well 95 or h4 or something like that
h4 there's probably this is probably
good young I have no no square really
this is again the problem
h4 is really bad if i go here what about
this one now it's probably also not bad
between here Quincy 7 yeah my day 3
again yeah the best one is really clean
a three and here besides look do you
want they're probably other moves the
compounds to play king h1 yeah that's
not bad that's a good prophylactic move
group fd1 it's also not bad yeah I just
forgot the Queen d7 motif and here
here's the easiest win this is the
easiest blackest black ass and then
terrible shape can something like this
and resins basically get this this was
really bad yeah okay thanks for watching